does every story begin with a log line
log lines are a writer's friend and I
think log
lines give the framework of the story so
many writers
are resistant to the log line and the
log line tells the executive tells
anyone who's asking what the story is
what the framework is and it shows that
the writer has thought out the concept
so value the process of doing a log line
because when you go to the page from the
log line it will be so much easier when
you're log line doesn't work your story
doesn't work so if you go to the page
and discover that the story is not
working it it starts with the log line
how does a log line determine whether
the story will work a log line if you
have the right components the writers
that I work with I utilize a formula to
help them which is setup of who create
empathy dilemma action goal Twist of
irony and I have so many writers who
will say oh my God I can't put all that
in a sentence but when when you do it
puts everything in order and it tells
you what is going to work what is not
going to work and one of the tools that
I learned helps writers is when the
adjective describing the central
character at the beginning of the log
line is something where we get a sense
of the Void so that creates empathy for
the character and we see how the goal is
a chance for the
transformation wow all that and just you
said you like to give how many
sentences I like to I like them to do it
in one sentence however two sentences
work I mean there are many people in the
industry who are fine with two sentences
as long as gravity is something that
that is there and we get a main sense of
the story points not a rambling second
sentence are there certain adjectives
that you prefer to use that void I like
any adjective where I can get a sense
of the earlier wound that creates some
type of
anticipation that creates some sense of
the flaw where I can get a sense of how
the
pursuit is going in a direction that
gives an opportunity to heal the earlier
wound does a screenwriter really need a
log line for their movie can't they do
it later after they've written the
script I know many writers that do the
log line later
and I think that works however my
preference
when when working with writers I notice
that when they have the log line it
helps them so much with going to the
outline in the script and when there is
a struggle it's because they don't have
a general outline of where they're going
now the log line can
change and when you start with log line
and then you see how the story comes
through you and you discover that the
story is different than where you
started with the log line then you just
rewrite the log line so it's not set in
stone that it's flexible
yes it is flexible the log line is
something that writers need to Value
because it's showing that you have a
wellth thought out concept where you are
able to deliver it in one or two lines
and the receiver immediately knows what
your story is do you find with some of
the people who take your courses um that
they're open to flexibility and maybe
some are more rigid and they have a hard
time being open to changes I find
resistance a lot lot
so I do feel that the value of doing
something like a course is that the
writer will get the information the
writer will see the story tool then they
will see the application of the story
tool with the clip and the example of a
show or film and how to apply the story
tool so the
courses even though you may have
resistance the value of doing a course
is that the writer understands your
philosophy on story so that it helps
them in knowing how to apply it so there
is a tremendous value in giving Story
tools giving philosophy and then
illustrating in action with shows or
films that are utilizing the story tool
at a high level so that the writer
understands how to use it is a log line
really the job of the screenwriter
shouldn't that be left to the marketing
department no that should not be left to
the marketing department I have
seen
marketing uh I remember there was a
series on Fox a number of years ago
where
the marketing department marketed the
show wrong and and because it was
marketed in a way and there was such
high hopes for the series but the
marketing made it seem like it's
something that it wasn't and when you
when I saw the show coming from a
current program a former current
programming executive point of view
I saw the reason that the audience
didn't show up because of that Gap that
now I think there are many marketing
professionals who know how to coin a
story in a way that maybe adds to the
writer's
intention however I feel that no one
knows the story like the writer what do
you mean when you say learn to identify
by the log lines in your own life
emotional truth so emotional truth is
for me something that adds depth when
you know the emotions that you're
exploring in a story when you've gone
through that emotion then you can take
us so much further into it and I feel
like with everything going on in the
world right now that people are craving
depth and authenticity and people are
craving the feeling of someone sees me
someone knows me and that only comes
from an emotional truth of someone who
has experienced something similar to
what the main character is going through
so you think maybe in the past we wanted
to see more of like a dream version of
who we are but then now we actually want
to see ourselves the warts and all
represented I do I I think that's very
well put it used to be that you wanted a
character you always want a character
you empathize with and you root for so
no matter how flawed a character is I
think the balance of finding POS
positive traits to negative traits is a
very big challenge because it is so
important for the writer to create a
vulnerability with the character that
lets the audience in and streaming
certainly has opened up the gate to
character arcs that are going so much
deeper and I think when I compare
streaming to television I feel like film
also goes to a depth that streaming goes
to and I think the network uh shows are
starting to catch up with that but I
feel like there's more Liberty in
streaming in film to go through the
transformational arc and to not feel the
surface part of the character but
through understanding the wound the flaw
the dream the biggest fear uh creating
multi-dimensional characters that mean
something